here's what would happen if you jumped
into Lake Natron this is one of the most
dangerous lakes in the world and could
actually turn you into stone but how
well taking a dip in this Lake you'd be
met with water that can be up to 60
degrees Celsius this would cause third
degree burns in about five seconds if
you stayed in long enough your entire
body would eventually Harden this is
thanks to Lake natron's high levels of
sodium and potassium carbonate
these chemicals would cause your body to
harden and eventually turn into stone if
someone were to stumble upon you
hundreds of years from now your body
would still be intact like mummification
Lake natron's extremely high levels of
alkalinity would stop the decomposition
process allowing you to be fully
preserved so